yep it's draining  [Music]  we were here on Monday and sent home  because it was manageable at home and  really we didn't see a lot of change but  my instinct this morning was like I need  to go back  [Music]  they're breathing harder they're  breathing faster their head Bobby  they're kind of moving their head back  and forth and they're making a grunting  noise that's when we want to take some  more action  [Music]  foreign  typically until December or January and  sometime into February this is going to  be a rough winter season  [Music]  our immune system has kind of taken a  holiday but now that we're back in  schools we're not wearing masks now  we're being re-exposed and now we're  seeing the numbers increase  [Music]  we're having patients in Hall beds we're  using our Orthopedic room we're using  other treatment rooms as much as  possible all hands on deck